art philosophy democracy and heroes
these are just a few achievements of the
legendary civilization known as ancient
Greece ancient Greece was born on the
shores of the Aegean Sea about 4000
years ago in over a millennium it
expanded to lands as far west as Spain
and as far east as India throughout this
age of empire the ancient Greeks made
political militaristic
and cultural achievements that resonated
long after their empire fell part of the
ancient Greeks legacy involved politics
one of which was the political system of
Greece itself unlike many nations that
were under unified rule Greece was a
collection of over 1500 territories that
acted as sovereign nations called
city-states these territories had their
own rulers and sometimes fought each
other another political development was
the institution of the first large-scale
democracy developed in the city-state of
Athens democratic rule was a way to give
the Greek people representation and
political power the Greeks also earned a
strong reputation for their military the
military helped expand the Greek Empire
by establishing colonies overseas and it
protected Greece itself from foreign
invaders like the Persian Empire when
such a threat occurred city-states
united to defend their homeland
many Greeks particularly in Sparta to
commence pride in their military and
regarded their soldiers as heroes their
heroism was often turned into legend
thanks to literary works like the Iliad
war heroes also inspired the creation of
the Olympics which celebrated physical
competition of all aspects of ancient
Greek civilization their cultural
contributions left a considerable mark
on the Western world particularly
noteworthy where the ancient Greeks art
and architecture they created incredible
sculptural works such as standing
figures and reliefs plus they developed
three types of columns and incorporated
them to structures like the Parthenon
this artistry was imitated by other
civilizations and spread throughout the
globe for thousands of years how the
Greeks interpreted the world was also
reflected in other cultures Greek
religion which was comprised of many
anthropomorphic deities helped shape the
spiritual beliefs of the Etruscans
and later the ancient Romans Greek
philosophy which explored matters of
Reason ethics and natural law influenced
later civilizations achievements in
politics and science Greek language made
quite an impact as well ancient Greek at
about 3400 years old provided the basis
of many modern languages the English
language alone has thousands of words
with Greek roots
ancient Greece's artistry regard for
heroes and democratic rule left a
considerable impression on world history
with contributions that lasted for
millennia the civilization of ancient
Greece is nothing short of legendary
[Music]